that leads us to our first conference
championship prop guys over under a
number of catches for marcus mariota on
sunday the over under number is 0.5 big
cat are you over or under the pity
package that's what i've been calling it
like hey man you're still partying
they're paying the guy 20 million
dollars they may as well have him do
something yeah i i feel bad for him i so
because i feel bad for him i'm gonna say
over marcus mario's gonna catch one pass
on sunday
i don't know who's gonna throw the pass
but he's gonna catch one pass oh i got
no pity for him did you just say he made
20 million dollars this year no pity
that's so i'm gonna go under though i
don't think he's gonna get a catch this
week i do think we'll see the package
you know where he's out on the field
maybe two or three plays especially
early on but i don't think he gets any
passes that go his way i don't think
mike frable will risk it
here's what i hope i hope he gets a snap
or two at quarterback and he throws a
pass and it gets tipped and he catches
his own pass again that's what i'm
hoping for so maybe we'll see some
marcus mariota who did play well two
years ago at arrowhead stadium all right
over under number of people derek harms
derek henry stiff arms to the ground 2.5
big cat what do you got
uh i'll take the over absolutely the
over the chiefs are not a good run
defense they're going to have trouble
tackling all day mike you just said
actually last segment i i think we we
glossed over that you said that they're
going to be able to limit eric henry by
going low that was your that was your
big time analysis like just go low like
no one no one has thought of that just
being
hey yeah just go low mike that's right
yeah that's it's not man you know the
titans are i mean the chiefs defender
defenders are probably watching this
going man that's a good point go low man
i should have listened to floria oh you
know the darrell rivas the darrell riva
strategy two years ago was get the hell
out of the way well yeah that's what i'm
picking under they're not going to let
themselves be stiff arm to the ground
they're just going to get out of the way
well it's going to be over there's
nothing you could do to get out of the
way with this damn guy he's so big his
arms are so long i mean what we've seen
him do in new england what we saw him do
last week to earl thomas where he like
throw him out there like a ragdoll like
he was his own personal protector as he
was running down the sidelines uh his
stiff arm is a legit weapon i mean and
people just crumble to the ground so i'm
with big cat there i'm going over as
well you said over mike
i'm saying under because they they're
going to get out of his way
they're not going to let themselves be
still what if your side arm you're on
the side or they're going to go running
for a 40-yard run you can't go low then
they're gonna have to come and try to
tackle them this the stiff arm to the
ground is a pretty rare play i mean he's
gonna run over a lot of people i just
think the actual use of the arm pressing
it to the head and throwing him to the
ground i think it'll be under two and a
half all right uh will this and this is
an up or down yes or no no 0.5 owned or
over under it's either going to happen
or it's not will it be mentioned during
the broadcast that patrick mahomes
didn't get to touch the ball in overtime
of last year's afc championship game
yes of course it'll be in the beginning
of the game it'll be in the intro of the
game does that count as part of the game
because it definitely has to be
mentioned yeah there will be there will
absolutely be a mention of this that's a
that's a no doubter oh
no
no yeah no doubter how about something
better how about will patrick mahomes
baseball career be mentioned in the
broadcast oh without a doubt jim nance
without a doubt i mean we're gonna hear
about didn't get the ball in overtime at
the beginning of the game like you said
big cat if the game's somewhat close in
the third quarter we will hear that two
more times and then the first time he
does the old you know read option and
throws a sidearm slant out there it's
going to be about the baseball thing
100 i'm with you there
what do you think we're going to hear
more about aaron rodgers will we hear
more that he's from the bay area or that
the 49ers passed on him in 2005. 49ers
passed on him 49ers passed on him is
going to be the big story because aaron
rodgers makes it a story he is a chip on
the shoulder type of guy where he's
still i mean how many years have passed
since this happened so but he still
talks about it and it still motivates
him so if it motivates you and you want
to talk about it it's going to be talked
about on the broadcast yeah i do think
it gets brought up but i still think the
fact that he's from the bay area will
win out that he's home and his family's
in the crowd and he admired joe montana
as a young kid like all those things are
going to come up at least multiple times
so i'm going with the over there as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports